I don't have anything to cheer us with
but that's no where's your drink I
didn't I was just gonna make this my
drink
welcome to its grace I'm here with
mamrie Hart and Hannah Hart you know
them from such works as other videos
we've done together yeah Hogwarts Oh
Camp Takota we're about to embark on
creating some of the most culturally
relevant artistically groundbreaking
performance art that you will have ever
seen in your life and that brings me to
today's challenge the fart sound board
challenge
pee-yew now the origin or the
inspiration for this challenge came when
we were creating her show over in London
and Dublin for the nofilter show and we
needed a fart sound for the end of our
opening number
and we went online or we found this
entire fart sound floors that just gave
you a variety of fart noises and we lost
our [ __ ] turned into a game a drinking
game of course thank you for the rules
we each one at a time we'll choose a
fart sound of our choice
tell each other what the sound with it
what it's called its name and then play
that sound if the other two people laugh
they have to take a drink if the other
people don't laugh the person that shows
the fart has to drink the first person
that has some that drinks three shots is
out okay but these are like baby shot
we're doing another shot we're doing
half shots yeah so that it doesn't
become this world shortest video so
there's in six shots okay all right
let's pour the shots oh good good good
that's not leather the tables for the
kill
there we go okay so for the first part
I'm going to choose I wanted to go to
choose my favorite one which is cello
below
[Music]
yeah here we go next
okay go buddy okay this is called air
biscuit
[Music]
no okay be able I think you drink if you
laugh on the title I also there's no
good I think we should drink blonde for
the title they're really smart although
I think that you should be allowed in an
effort to make somebody laugh but to
pretend that you're producing like a
cello below everybody be like float up a
little all right fart noise BMX Lex
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah
Michael joins the drink now No
so what's the score I have one no you up
- no I wouldn't cause we're doing half
shots oh I get took one so far
okay so favorite here she's has like a
half of them and then what do you have
you have half the fart I'm choosing it's
called
and that's the truth and that's the
truth
this little ditty is called dueling
buttholes
I repeat dueling buttholes
[Music]
okay variety show never you drink okay
maybe doesn't do liquor no nice and I
teach it Saturday yeah you should say
that this part reminds me of a classical
piece you might know as we journey with
the [ __ ] of the bumblebee sparked
really like I didn't like and
wait let's watch shots for the lead oh
my god I mean I already know that I'm
gonna win this no I got this all right
you ready this - called
Laurel and party tuna-melt madness it's
a classic we all know and love I present
to you Puff Daddy okay
they call this one the hiney hiccup
[Applause]
moving on to prelude to a crap
[Applause]
okay guys still for the win burning
something stuttering on the John no but
we always pretend like it's us we
participated in the inaugural farts
sound board challenge I encourage you
all to challenge your friends just
search for fart sounds in Google and
you'll find the sound book that we use
this is a sponsored video sponsored by
poo pourri
we'll go over and check out how to name
rim blah blah blah yadda yadda yadda I
like for us to each do a fart noise out
of our mouths gonna name it
Oh are we fighting in real life
fart Garfunkel a gallery my Suri Cruise
[Music]
it's a pop fart oh I can just pop down
the toaster we make videos over on MAME
town and on my heart oh / just heart oh
now hey vintage vintage Hannover common
look sighs bah